eine App zur besseren Bewirtschaftung
der Felder
Lehrstunden in Sauberkeit und
Arbeitsschutz und praktische Übungen zur
richtigen Behandlung der Ernte die
Herausforderungen des Klimawandels und
die Spielregeln internationaler Märkte
bestimmen auch das Leben ägyptischer
Bauern
mit mehreren feldschulen im Gebiet
südlich von Kairo will die Deutsche
Gesellschaft für internationale
Zusammenarbeit Ihnen dabei helfen diese
Herausforderungen zu meistern
auch von total Gede
1100 die Leute von der GEZ haben uns von
diesem Unterricht erzählt es kommen
Lehrer und Ingenieure und erklären uns
was wir tun sollen wir lernen ziemlich
viel
ermutigen auch die Frauen hier
mitzumachen
sie können das gleiche wie die Männer
manche sogar mehr
es ist gar nicht so schwer alte
Gewohnheiten zu ändern
das neue kommt das alte geht dazu
gehören alte Geräte wie der schwingflug
das sind alte Bewässerungsmethoden wenn
einmal im Jahr der Nil die Landschaft
entlang seiner Ufer flutet und das sind
altbekannte Pflanzen wie zum Beispiel
die Mango denn gerade die Mango Ägyptens
wohl bekannteste Frucht tut sich schwer
mit den Bedingungen des Klimawandels
das Wetter verändert sich jetzt so
schnell es ist nicht mehr so stabil wie
früher du kommst aus dem Winter und zack
bist du im Sommer du kommst aus dem
Sommer und bist im Winter für die Mango
ist das alles ziemlich schlecht
viele Kräuter und Heilpflanzen aber Anis
Kamele Majoran Pfefferminz oder
Basilikum kommen gut zurecht mit
Klimabedingungen wir sehen Oberägypten
herrschen
sie vertragen Wärme und verlangen nicht
viel vom Boden
der Boden muss gut vorbereitet sein das
haben wir schon gelernt
und wir haben gelernt die Pflanzen zehn
Tage vor der Ernte nicht mehr zu
bewässern dann geht das Mähen viel
besser und wir müssen auch das Unkraut
herauszupfen
der Ort an dem sie das gelernt haben ist
eine der feldschulen der GEZ mehr als
6000 Bauern soll in diesen Schulen das
Grundwissen vermittelt werden um
ökologische und nachhaltige
Landwirtschaft zu betreiben und
profitabel zu wirtschaften
geflutete Felder im Nil Delta über
Jahrhunderte hat der Fluss mit seinen
scheinbar unbegrenzten Wassermengen den
Bauern diese Art der Bewässerung
ermöglicht jetzt kommt die Nilflut
seltener und schwächer Wasser wird immer
kostbarer es heißt umdenken
80% des nilwassers gehen in die
Landwirtschaft also müssen wir das
kontrollieren
den Bauern bei wie Sie die Pflanzen
anbauen müssen um mit wenig Wasser
auszukommen
auszurechnen wie viel Wasser die Pflanze
braucht
und sie müssen auch wissen wann Sie am
besten Gießen sollen nämlich morgens
oder am späten Nachmittag
nun und heute wissen sie auch es kommt
auf das Saatgut an alte Sorten passen
nicht in neue Zeiten und viele alte
Gewohnheiten auch nicht so müssen die
Bauern zum Beispiel verstehen wie
wichtig es ist auf die Sauberkeit ihrer
Geräte zu achten beim Lernen spricht der
Lehrer die Worte vor und seine Schüler
wiederholen Sie zum Reinigen vier Tassen
Wasser und eine Tasse Chlor
und dann üben sie es mischen im
Verhältnis 1 zu 4 solange bis es sitzt
change das Denken zu verändern braucht
Zeit deshalb sind wir hier draußen auf
den Feldern wir müssen den Bauern Wissen
vermitteln und Ihnen gleichzeitig zeigen
wie Sie es anwenden können
und sie lernen auch was sie nicht mehr
tun sollen nämlich chemischen Dünger
einsetzen Chemie soll so weit wie
möglich eingeschränkt werden wegen der
Umwelt und für bessere Marktchancen für
das
dabei zuerst geht es darum die
Biodiversität des Bodens
wiederherzustellen also Kompost zu
verwenden um den Boden zu verbessern
[Musik]
und weil wir auf dem internationalen
Markt mitmischen wollen müssen unsere
Produkte nicht nur sauber sein sondern
auch biologisch
so viel Neues so viele Herausforderungen
da ist es wichtig dass die Bauern nicht
nur die Mühe sehen sondern auch die
Erfolge
wenn meine Kräuter frei von Pestiziden
sind bekomme ich das Doppelte des
früheren Preises
ich verdiene mehr und es ist gesünder
was wir hier lernen führt dazu dass
unsere Ernte besser ist
und gute Ware hat auch bessere Chancen
beim Export
aber nur auf dem Feld alles richtig zu
machen dass allein reicht noch nicht um
gegen internationale Konkurrenz bestehen
zu können also versucht die GEZ die
Bauern Ihres Projektes auch fit zu
machen auf dem digitalen Feld
seine eigens für sie entwickelte App
soll sie mit allen Informationen
versorgen die es für ein erfolgreiches
Wirtschaften braucht
man zum einen unterstützen wir die
Bauern mit Informationen wo Sie am
Besten Werkzeug Saatgut oder Dünger
kaufen können
zweitens hilft Ihnen die App beim Umgang
mit dem Wetter wenn sie auf dem Feld
sind
und sie liefert auch noch Informationen
über die aktuelle Marktsituation so kann
jeder Bauer seine Waren direkt über die
App verkaufen
noch ist die App in der Erprobungsphase
noch fehlen Erfahrungen in der täglichen
Anwendung aber alle sind sich bewusst
die Herausforderungen denen die
Landwirte gegenüberstehen sind
vielfältig und die Antworten müssen es
auch sein
die GEZ will Ihnen dabei helfen diese
Antworten zu finden
[Musik]